[Music]
in the latest in crazy customer news all
right submitted by what happened to the
kung-fu alright a woman was arrested for
biting off a Chinese restaurant owner's
ear during a dispute over the food damn
like Tyson that [ __ ] she's like I'd
rather eat your ear [ __ ] oh yeah prove
it and she's like that might just be a
delicacy out there who knows did you
guys see uh they did a Michigan what was
it again a Chinese restaurant a Chinese
restaurant a woman a Chinese restaurant
I thought it could have been in China
too it's just called the restaurant
overhead that's true did you guys see
the video Tyson returning the ear back
to hope you'll know that is amazing is
that really so he goes did they shoot it
like like a sitcom like 90s sitcom you
go sting dong and then a Holyfield
opens uh children actual holy flippin
the door Mike Tyson's Ike is like I have
to it I'm sorry Evander who takes it in
a box leg that's it where was this place
why did Mike Tyson half his ear I know I
know but why did he have the oh no no
it's like a commercial or something it's
like hey it's like afterward the ref
comes up to me he's like hey wanted to
get you the ear that you've been off it
is yours because you bit it off like you
kept it in his mouth that's pretty bit
it just hit it yeah oh so what happened
with this crazy-ass [ __ ] well this
crazy-ass [ __ ] here so this takes place
in Michigan
anybody that bites off here in the
middle of a fight is crazy yeah this
one's even crazier because it's in the
middle of a restaurant so it's like you
hungry yes so she apparently there was
some sort of dispute over the food she
was arguing with the female owner
sounds about right and then so like when
the young son came to help his mom well
general Hall Diaz but apparently this
[ __ ] Jayde
who's 24 years old punched the kid in
the face starting and was attacking them
all after a bit the year - oh no no no
before hos first the son the if it was
first a mom the female owner right then
they start fighting the Sun comes in
tries to help the mom Jade ends up
punching the son in the face and then
continues to fight with the mom and
that's when the husband comes in tries
to help and then that's when Jade a part
of his part of it that's why it was but
they only had I've known his crazy [ __ ]
I went to Chinese people Oh
why the dad the dad is bleeding the dad
ears are bleeding her out like holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] man was detached yeah I'm
crazy damn how does she get so close to
his ear because he was trying to
separate her from his wife I don't know
what happened like do they forget like
the soy sauce or some [ __ ] like that
like what is the reason this is an
authentic Chinese food
it's like you're a Michigan 1/8 [ __ ]
expecting she's not real Chinese food
she's a Chinese food connoisseur like
Chinese food
it's a favor she like to him it outraged
her dude there what happened to leaving
a yelp review or something yeah
apparently the kid said she got a refund
- right yeah so she got a refund then
she threw for two the four and when I
was taking the son I was thinking like
an older son though he even tells a
story like a kid does yeah dad he came
up and he started hitting my mom and
then he started hitting me like it's
like I need a weird kid yeah kids like
well people get scared no we should make
fun of them
I love it honesty that's what it is it's
like kids aren't afraid to just [ __ ]
tell it as it is you know because it's
like a full-grown adult is gonna be I'm
[ __ ] scared right now
it isn't Jade the name of like a Chinese
like Beauty jewel or gem like yeah so
ironic I thought that there's gonna be a
agen lady yeah exactly I was surprised
by that was like hey that's what dogs do
though like dogs [ __ ] bite you in the
mid middle of chaos and [ __ ]
that's crazy well your adrenaline is
rushing though you don't know what
you're gonna do that's why what happened
to Mike Tyson you know I mean he got so
angry there's a professional fighter
resort of dividing so you ever talked
about it was you're like yeah I just
lost my [ __ ] man sound like you bit his
own tongue off yeah yeah doesn't happen
he sounds like he has too much tongue
yeah exactly yeah I'm he has a little
scrape that's too much
dude that's crazy yeah I mean was the
orange chicken bad or like what cuz I
don't know lady
just [ __ ] crazy because then it turns
out to her defense though there's some
there's some food that I've eaten that I
did want to [ __ ] throw it back at the
restaurant owners and get angry at
because was so bad I don't think she
even ate food so she cooky actually I
don't know where I got it in my mind
that in my mind I got I for some reason
I picked her here getting takeout but ya
know she punched the mom punched a kid
and bit the dad right yeah that's pretty
crazy yeah it seems like she's crazier
than we expected because she left a
small child at home during me oh man I
know what happened now she's on meth she
ordered some food and maybe got
delivered to her she picked it up and
she took it home and then her order was
wrong and then she went back to go fix
that the [ __ ] and get a refund and she
probably wanted gas money
Oh oh man I've never even thought about
gas money why would you leave your kid
at home and go to a restaurant oh she
would have brought the she was just so
infuriated that she was just forgot
about everything else and she just was
like tunnel vision that's what I'm
saying that that kind of stuff is very
infuriating like say you know when you
get a post mates order and they forget a
thing like Sophos think about how pissed
you get about that they always forget
ketchup and gentles
and that's fine is when they forget an
entire like right you're like oh just
recently I ordered some food and his
lady marked it as completed and I waited
like 15 minutes in like maybe she she
accidentally wants to complete her
whatever this [ __ ] never showed up
never called me nothing keeping her
waiting forever for her food I got so
mad cuz i was already angry so then i
called the customer service and they
tell me like oh yeah she accidentally
did it whatever i was like you know
whatever give me a refund I went myself
to the restaurant how close Rita you're
biting on this meter how close to eat do
you're biting uncle Oh Shay pretty up
there you're up there right cuz you're
hangry [ __ ] you already had to deal with
this [ __ ] now you gotta get up and go
out and you were waiting for the orders
never contact you it's a go to the
restaurant drive and you do [ __ ] poor me
I had to drive over there well you don't
like it
man your refund he wasn't there so tip
what's left will get to the ear biting
from there
yeah maybe the owner not wanting to give
you the [ __ ] rewrite yeah go and pick
it up I think my chick J dude I think
she got a [ __ ] threat that's what
happened like to take uppercase I said
I'm tell you that's how you get you get
angry so fast like that I mean one thing
about pose means that pissing me off is
like I live in an apartment building and
when they don't come all the way to my
door yeah what do they do leave it on
the [ __ ] doorstep of the party but
now this is B by the lobby and be like
yogurt come down did you come down
because I'm in a situation you know
what's even crazier is like so we live
in a house one it's like one wants to
sort of it the front door like you don't
have to walk anywhere other than the
front door and then they'll call me hey
we're all front and then they're like
I'm like what the [ __ ] just our front
door hasn't moved
that's the way to if they don't come to
my door I usually iio his this is my
thing I got on they call me like could
you come down like parking is crazy or
something you know I'd be like I can't
watch you my kid my baby I have a baby
yeah they have the car not gonna leave
my baby over there
I got a two-month-old right here I can't
leave her yeah that's really good as
dude I pause mate at one time in this
lady full-on was like you know can I
pull up outside and just like [ __ ]
throw the sandwich at you could I get
another order right now and I was like
god dammit but I did it she [ __ ]
throw - like a football
basically honestly yeah I'm not even
kidding right now I got like a firehouse
subs thing and she just like she was in
a real hurry cuz she had I guess a
bigger catering order that she had to
get you and she gets way massive tips on
that she was like just playing the whole
thing to me on the phone I was just like
I don't want to deal with this [ __ ] I'll
just [ __ ] go out there I don't care
but I also I also like my apartment when
you're walking through it it like looks
kind of seedy and [ __ ] so I don't blame
them for being like yo can I mean just
like yeah come to the door I'll go down
I'll go down to the lobby a lot of times
but sometimes if like you know sometime
when you're sick in your post maybe you
don't want to go down you've been in
your house all day and that's why the
your a post me like if I would have gone
down to the lobby I would have gone to
the [ __ ] restaurant
you know what I'm saying like back out
of scenario like that's why I order post
me so you deliver straight to the door I
could be in my boxers and [ __ ] and when
people say that things are worse now
than ever this is the [ __ ] that makes me
laugh I don't want to [ __ ] go to the
lobby you're right you're you're in your
house all [ __ ] day and you're in your
underwear you're comfortable like all
the older generations like a Baptist
like you piece of [ __ ] you kidding me
right you are a piece of [ __ ] I had to
kill a pig and the pig I grew up with
that [ __ ] pig you know what I don't
have to eat it that's all right I don't
like the whole you know always comedians
are older [ __ ] always want to
hate on that whole kind of you know
[ __ ] who like live in the now
and have like first world problems
that's how it is like that's how the
[ __ ] world is now look you're like so
deal with it like you know what that is
my complaint and I'm sticking with it
all right [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] that come to
the [ __ ] door come to the door I have
a [ __ ] fake invisible child in my
[ __ ] house hey old comedians yeah it's
true that's all I gotta say about that
yeah what do you yeah like louis c.k on
the plane he's like I don't have Wi-Fi I
don't have Wi-Fi with the blood
[Laughter]
[Music]